Okay, so let's continue our discussion.
So far we were talking about feed
forward neural network that is basically
a stack of u this layers of perceptrons
which we called multi-layer perceptrons.
So they uh have proven
very efficient uh to be used in tabular
data. For example, they are heavily used
in tasks like fraud detection and
recommener systems. So when trained on
historical data, often they can
outperform even human experts on the
such tasks.
However, one task that remained
stubbornly difficult for uh such
machines were image recognition. I mean
even complex multi-layer perceptrons uh
they fail to match performance that we
we desire basically something close to
the human level performance. So to
understand that uh we need to look at uh
the challenges that we have in uh image
recognition. So recall that basically
uh any neural network is basically a way
of approximating a function
and uh by approximating a function we
said that is effectively fitting a curve
in
uh among the observed data points. So
for example, let's assume a
one-dimensional case where we have a
one-dimensional X that is coming um to
our neural network and we are asking our
nor to return uh a decision maybe a 01
decision. Uh so maybe X is uh just a
classification problem uh that we have a
bunch of images image of one maybe image
of two or let's make it more interesting
maybe image of zero and image of six
because they are it can be kind of
similar. So let's uh assume this uh
train of data is coming and they get
some values on x like this and our uh
normal network uh is basically
uh has to fit a curve between them.
Basically when it gets six we want a
decision six
and when it gets zero we want the
decision zero. So basically we have two
decision here. Uh so here we are asking
our neural network to basically
fit a curve here right. So something
like this. So if we had a a
one-dimensional
uh data space we could fill it up very
quickly with uh observed data. Right? So
for example, let's assume we have in our
problem if if we had a 1D uh space, we
could fill it up with non data points,
right? So uh if this 1D goes to 2D, we
need exponentially more data. So maybe 9
to 2. And if we have ND, we are looking
at 9 to n. So what does this mean when
we are dealing with image? So for
example if our image is a 32x 32 pixel
right uh in this case and even if we
have uh like RGB channel three channel
here in this case we are looking at 372
or um or in the same analogy here n is
so we want 3 9 raised to 372
data points to have a sufficiently
um filled up space for our no network to
fit the curve.
This is a large number I mean
astronomically large.
So there that's why no matter how smart
we train our neural network or our MLP
with a architecture like that uh and
such inductive bias we will always
struggle.
So for example in a CR 10 data set the
best that I've seen that we could we can
do is an accuracy of 74%.
And uh if you compare this to human
level which is 99%
it's very very far. So okay. So let me
show you um another reason basically
like I said if we uh what we have done
so far with MLP
uh and uh basically classification of
images like the amnesa
we flatten the the image or pixels into
a vector for example in a 32x 32 image
and um if you flatten this and we give
it to the MLP, it can give us a pretty
good result. Uh when we when we expect
uh one to be here, it will be always
here. It will not be here for example.
So and uh the emata is basically
prepared like that initially by Leon and
his team to be like that. But what does
this mean? This means basically if we
shuffle the pixels and uh we send the
same flattened vector to the MLP
um it's just basically order has changed
and the MLP can still uh do the
classification
and in other word if we send an an input
which looks like completely noisy image
and give it to the neural network it can
uh tell you with high confidence that
this is for example no number three mean
let's ask uh ourselves what we are
expecting nano to do and compare it to
what we are doing as humans.
So the reason humans are able to see
it's because our brain have a lot of
information and knowledge about the
world. It has some expectation, some
regularity
uh that uh works like an structure. Uh
and uh this structure basically makes it
easy for us to look at an image and
screen the image for features and then
put together these features and then
decide what is inside this image. So the
idea here is let's give some insight
some structure to the neural networks
and make the job easier for it. So let's
infuse some of this structure that we
know and we can provide that to the
neural network and then design a neural
network with such inductive bias. So two
principles that we can consider. So
first principle
spatial locality the neural network
that when it's looking at a pixel it
consider that this pixel is not alone
and it has uh some local neighborhood
and the pattern that comes from this
neighborhood. We are not expecting that
there is a relationship between this
pixel and some very distant pixel. The
second principle is if you see the same
feature here or here for example, it's
the same feature. So if there's an edge
for example or a whisker of a cat, it's
still whisker. So in your next level of
reasoning you can use uh the same
feature same way. So if we have a a
feature extractor that is working over
this local neighborhood the same feature
extractor can work here. So what does
that mean? That means that if I have a
neural network that is looking at this
uh and take this as an input and gives
out the features the same neural network
basically should work here too. So we
don't want to train another one. It's
basically the same neural network that
we are moving or screening the the image
with sweeping the image with and uh uh
it works the same. It's the same with
the same parameters that looks at this
uh patches of image and gives out the
features. So what did I say? I said
basically this can give us a strategy
instead of one very large massive
network that is looking at the image at
its entirety. What if we use a very
small neural network that an analyze u
one small patch of the image at a time
and we slide it across the entire image
to find uh those features everywhere.
The idea is not really novel here.
Basically what we are saying is
something that we have done previously
in computer vision and back then in uh
before heavy use of neural network what
did we do in computer vision was some
form of filters that is looking at this
patches and uh give us the feature.
These filters were engineered. So the
good thing about this um filters that
also called kernels
are basically they are interpretable
right uh uh we know what they are doing
what they are looking for
however they have a limited
expressiveness
they can only detect a simple predefined
pattern that they are designed for. we
have to make a decision which filters or
kernels to use. So we said we are
looking at basically sweeping a function
a filter a kernel
uh across the data and this u kernel
will give us some form of information
that we can use as a feature. Right? So
as we said we are looking at a function
that slides over the values of data. I
mean for example in the case of images
we are sliding over the patches of data.
Uh in a case of maybe much simpler
situation when we have a train of um
data points coming basically in a time
series we can look at um some local
windowing operation. For example, at
each uh window of uh length three,
we can uh get a value that is a smooth
version of these three data points. And
this is basically a kernel of the shape,
right? Basically what it does, it um
adds up all of these values within that
window. So this was the moving average
that we do.
And probably in daily life if you are a
time series analyst and this is a an
example that uh is very common and it
does what it does is a local operation
and a kernel that slides through each
one of these points. So for example next
window will be
here right and so on and so forth. We we
can start from here for the first one
and then window moves here then here
then goes like this and um I mean if you
heard of the the
term crossorrelation this is some form
of crossorrelation right basically we
crossorrelate all of these windows uh
with the kernel using this kernel. If we
do the same thing from 1D to 2D, this
corresponds to what we do as image
blurring. So same process, we define a
small window and a kernel
and uh this kernel has some weights. So
we have to choose this kernel. We can do
the same uniform weight kernel for
example. Uh they sum up to one and
basically we place the kernel over each
patch of this input image.
perform an elementwise multiplication
between the kernel's weights and the
corresponding pixel values in that
patch. Then we sum up all the values and
all the results of that multiplication
to get a single new pixel value. And
then we slide the window across the
entire image and repeat the same process
for every location we create a new
blurred image. Right? So we can do more
than im image blurring. For example, we
can do edge detection and even uh
sharpening of those edges
and um for example in the edge detection
a famous filter is soil filter that has
both positive and negative values again
sums up to zero and it slides over a
flat uniform region and the output will
be zero in that case. But if it slides
over an edge, a sharp change in pixel
values, the sum of the products becomes
larger u in positive or negative ways
and this highlights the the edge right
because the value will increase. So if
we want to formalize this in a
mathematical way basically for an um
pixel of um uh in i and j we sum up
um a pointwise
uh operation between the filter at A and
B and the pixel value at X and basically
since we are sliding through the the
pixel values uh here in 2D situation we
have both axis X and Y which here I use
the index a and So basically we have a
sum
this operation is known uh we call this
crossorrelation
and um and h is the output of this
feature map. So like I said
mathematically this is crossorrelation
although because we are cool we are
calling it convolution. In pure math,
convolution really uh involves a
flipping of the kernel first. Uh but
since later we will discuss the case
that uh what if we don't know V and we
want to learn it uh really flipping the
value uh doesn't really matter in that
case because it's done by itself. So it
will be convolution at the end.
So basically what we are saying is
instead of using this handcrafted
kernels that computer visions uh expert
uh design for us and each one of them
works for a specific feature. We want to
continue the the same paradigm in the c
that we have in the course. We want to
learn these features and uh like I said
in an end toend way uh features that are
working for the task that we want task
that we want and they are optimal for
that task. We don't want to go learn the
domain of computer vision and all of
these kernels and then uh develop u um
skill on how to make this tradeoffs and
make this decisions to basically use
this dictionary of fixed kernel. And
instead we want deep learning to do all
of that for us. learn the kernels and
these kernels are actually optimized for
the specific task that we have.
Crossorrelation or sweeping uh function
that learns this features in each one of
these patches of the window has a nice
property that is called translation
equivalence. If you shift the input, for
example, if you have a image of a cat
here, if you move this to somewhere else
in the image, it's the same thing. And
we want the neural network to uh not use
uh extra learning
capacity for that. In other word, we
have the same neural network that learns
this kernel works here and here. And
that uh sharing of weights across all of
this position give us a parameter
efficiency that later help us in such
high dimensional space because we really
reduce the dimension significantly by
doing this. So then uh next we will talk
about how we can build such uh neural
network that we are going to call
convolutional neural network. So before
applying this concepts uh to build our
first convolutional neural network
uh let's um review a couple of things.
First how we are using this kernel on
this image data and things that we
should consider in the implementation.
So for example here this is an image
from the book. If we have a kernel like
this and an image u here a 3x3 image or
maybe a patch but let's assume the image
is like this and now we want to do the
convolution or the cross correlation
operation using this kernel. So here we
have this 2x2 kernel and we are going to
start from this part of the image. we do
the elementwise
uh crossorrelation operation and this
will give us the first output here which
will be 19. If we continue doing this
for the next part of the image we'll get
25 and so on and so forth. So we will
see the output of this operation
here will be a 2x2
uh output which is smaller uh in
dimension than the the original input
and if we continue doing this uh steps
we will
end up in the next step with only one
out output. So what is the problem here
is uh sometimes we need more layers in
our operation in our convolutional
neural network and this operation will
reduce the size of uh the dimension of
the the data.
So to fix this uh very simple trick is
to pad the uh the data with this
zeros here. And basically what it does
is to in this case of 2x two we can now
uh have a output uh corresponding to
this edge cases on the periphery of the
the image. And this way we will retain
the same dimension
in the output. So keeping aside this
problem of u reduction of uh dimension
using padding
sometimes we actually want to reduce the
the dimension.
And if we want to do it we will use
strides
but basically stride is uh the number of
rows and columns that we traverse per
slide.
So so far uh we used the strides of one
but we can change that and uh we can
also change it for heights and weights.
So for example here this is figure 7 33
in the book. If we do the stride of uh
three for height and two for the widths.
For example, in the first one we have
this and the component wise we will get
that. But next uh stride will be two in
the whites. So we have this multiply by
this and we will get that. And the for
the height we go uh three we slide this
uh three times and we will get this
which multiply by the kernel will give
us six. And of course for the other
component if you do it you will get
eight.
So this way we can reduce the the
dimension uh if we desire and while we
are controlling for it. The next
component that we will use in
constructing our CNN's
are is uh pooling. Basically pooling
means that we ask a question from the
learned features and this question is a
global question meaning that does it
does this image contain a certain
feature or a certain object.
We want this question to be sensitive to
the entire input.
So we need to aggregate u this local
information gradually and uh this way we
can get coarser and coarser maps and
ultimately learning a global
representation.
So we want to do this in a way that we
keep all of these advantages that we
collect in these intermediate layers and
while we are going deeper in the network
we see more and more uh of this local
localities and our receptive field
relative to this initial input will
increase. So and also if you remember we
wanted our representation to be
invariant to translation
and so far what we did with the cross
correlation uh was pretty local. We were
sliding that window and we performed
cross cororrelation
uh during each one of these strides. And
now we want to come up with a another
step that uh basically inject this
invariance to translation and pooling is
doing that for us.
We have two ways of doing uh this
process this pooling step step uh I mean
most uh common way of pooling one is max
pooling and the other one is average
pooling and max pooling basically what
it does is uh it finds the strongest
clue and the intuition is basically each
one of these uh smaller uh
crossorrelation steps that we are doing
is like a detective that is zooming in
into this smaller patches and then after
aggregating all of them it returns the
strongest evidence that it finds. That's
max pooling. Another way of doing this
is doing average pulling which is
basically to average out all of this uh
evidence that it finds this detective
that we have and at the end it gives us
a smooth more general summary of those
features that it finds. So usually you
will see that we go with max pooling uh
because of this sharper aggregation that
it has.
But of course all of these uh both of
these methods are uh providing this
translation invariance that is the key
for us for the image data. So uh we are
going to use all of uh this uh
principles and these tools in building
our CNNs. Well, uh we will review the uh
history of this CNN architectures and
the reason is as you saw basically C
what CNN does is uh it starts from some
early layers that learns uh features
that can be generic and
um with the intermediate layer we will
aggregate this generic features to build
up larger
parts of the images for example
textures, patterns, uh eyes, wheels and
leaves. So you may ask yourself well can
I uh use this uh features that I learn
from some other network even uh in my
own network without training those uh
early layers for the task that I'm
interested in. So for instance, if we
have a network that is trained on a very
very large data set which requires uh a
lot of training and a lot of resources,
for example, a data set like imageet
that has a thousand classes like dog,
car, chair and so on and so forth. uh
the ability of this CNN to basically
detect edges, textures, shapes and
eventually objects can be reused in
another neural network and we basically
we can freeze that though that that
early layers and we don't need to really
train that part and then add more layer
after that to process these features in
a way that we want for the specific task
that we are interested in. So this is
known as transfer learning that uh
justifies
training a very very good architectures
as some sort of pre-trained network that
can be used elsewhere. So usually what
we do is we uh split the model uh the
CNN model in two parts. One is the
convolutional base which is basically
this early layers that we discussed that
uh they do the feature extraction and
then we have an we have a head at the
end that aggregate the this final
aggregated uh features that uh basically
use them. It can be even a linear MLP
that uses these features just like a
regression that uses the feature and
make a decision on for example if this
is a cat or dog uh while we are using
this convolutional base that can do much
more than just detecting cat and dog.
But for some reason you're only
interested in this final task and you
can use this overengineered
convolutional base that can give you
your cat and dog detection uh with very
high confidence while you haven't really
done any of that training and somebody
else did it with a very ad advanced
state-ofthe-art CNN base. So it's enough
to just replace the head and with a few
shot training in your own data set for
example you can train that part this
classification head while you're not
touching the the base. This basically
justifies training very good
convolutional bases. And uh we will talk
about some famous uh convolutional bases
that we can use uh in our own tasks and
we can just basically take them and
uh without training. We just need to
train some classification head at the
end and that doesn't really require a
lot of training and a lot of data.